hello everybody this is chess grandmas
yaser seran bringing you broadcast
coverage of the 37th chess Olympiad here
in Turin Italy I have as my guests two
Norwegian Grand Masters Simon agin on my
far left and young Magnus Carlson
sitting next to me this is your first uh
Olympiad uh Magnus how is uh your
individual result H well it's not my
first Olympia actually okay well there
you go
sorryi Norway a question for amongus uh
about move 19 uh it looked like you
touched one piece and moved another uh
could you just explain what
happened I mean not this again uh this
happens in every single world
championship match like clearly some
pieces are adjusted and um uh you know
um and it's with no intent to to move so
do
better and uh I do hope for
my um opponent today as well that um
even though the last two games weren't
so good um perhaps with the some some
changes you know some new people to to
work with better influences maybe he can
um he can play even better Magnus uh
you're saying better influences are you
talking about Hans nean right
now uh I'm talking about influences in
in general Magnus tomorrow you're moving
on to play the young Notre Beck of duur
a world rapid Champion how excited do
you get for matches like that against
players who potential World Championship
level Talent so how excited do you get
for matchups like
that he's washed he was champion in 2021
and I took it back in
2022 you're right I'm sorry Magnus you
could you seem to have some hiccups
earlier today you didn't have really
smooth performances and this game wasn't
that smooth either it looked a little
bit unclear what was your feeling
overall as the the game was
transpiring okay I mean what do you want
me to do so I mean I I take I take the
pce and then I mean of course he he
hasn't done anything particularly wrong
of course he's not going to be lost I
mean what do you what do you want from
me I I don't want anything I just want
to see just chess getting played yeah
but I mean you're talking about I mean
that the game wasn't smooth enough I
again what do you what do you want me to
do I
mean yeah sure oh I mean do you want me
to to get a huge Advantage from from the
opening and then to push it all the way
is that the only way you can win a
smooth game is that your point oh not at
all Magnus but certainly the game was
tricky enough let me get your thoughts
on how you've done far I'm just feeling
that the whole you know the whole the
way you're approaching it is trying to
belittle the whole thing that's my only
my apies Magnus we definitely have
respect for you as a world champion so
don't take it any offense to what we're
trying to say we're just trying to do
commentary you've got this out of the
way now it's time for Blitz your
thoughts on your rest of the
tournament hopeful that I can continue
to to yeah to win not so smooth games
and uh when you played B5 and Magnus
gave Queen A3 check you were not on the
board for quite some time you were in
your uh in the restroom uh did you
calculate after Queen A7 Bishop takes H3
what was going through your mind because
there still seemed like black could
defend better right uh well obviously um
black could defend better but in general
I felt like uh okay uh for quite some
time I was I was regretting of playing
B5 although I think uh after Bishop H3
okay there is like capturing on F7 some
Rook E8 I believe some Rook E8 check or
something yes so no but Rook E8 there's
Rook G6 sorry Rook E8 there's Rook G6 so
I mean a check Queen
A7 yeah I mean I take with the queen
because if I take with the bishop
there's Rook G6 no but which moment you
e Rook E8 King H7 Bishop F7 there's Rook
G6 well again like Queen E3 okay Queen
E3 check King G8 Queen takes A7 Bishop
H3 and if Rook check Rook E8 King H7
takes on F7 Bishop F7 Rook G6 Rook G6
here yeah okay it would be
something
yeah
just I didn't touch
it
make